the global pandemic is hitting the
cruise industry hard
the collapse of international travel
means the industry is losing around
one billion dollars a month in revenue
but some of those empty ocean liners are
fueling a different kind of tourism
industry along the english coast
holly williams has the story the cruise
industry has literally
ground to a halt its floating fun
palaces
now lie empty and eerily quiet
many of the giants are now moored off
england's south coast
where it's free for them to drop anchor
with just a skeleton crew on board
you're one of the first to book well
done hello but now one
enterprising englishman becky lovely has
devised an ingenious plan to make
money in the middle of a pandemic
welcome on board for who wants to go and
see some ships
running cruisers to see empty cruise
ships
the normal crew complement is
daily tours charging 25 ahead
to see the hulking ocean liners on his
own
tiny ferry boat so we advertised it on
facebook i have two cruises
and within four hours we'd filled up
four cruises
anthem of the seas has room for nearly 5
000
passengers and is decked out with a wave
machine
skydiving simulator its own
theatre 18
restaurants and a
30 foot high giraffe named gigi
gigi now stands for lawn on deck
as lonely as the crew members still on
board the anthem
they don't get much excitement out here
and next door
is her biggest sister allure of the seas
has a maximum capacity of nearly
seven thousand passengers she's roughly
five
times the size of the titanic and at
this time of the year she should be
cruising in the mediterranean sea
some of paul's passengers admit they're
here because there's not much else to do
with vacations off limits like josie and
david bintcliff
who enjoy traveling the world but not on
a cruise ship
we like adventure not keen to share a
tin box with 5000 other people
but vin mann a train driver and
transport enthusiast
told us it doesn't get more exciting
than this
being right up close to these massive
ships the biggest ships in the world
yeah it's just amazing seeing them up
close life hasn't been the same for
anyone for the last few months
but one man in a boat has found a way to
capitalize on it for cbs this morning
saturday
holly williams near mudderford in
england
i love that guy i don't see the appeal
it's kind of cool i mean
you're on a cruise ship so you see from
the inside you never really look at it
right outside even from the dock you
wouldn't see it the same way
i just like the honesty of there's not
really a lot to do too so no five bucks
if you have the money
go see it go get out on the water five
times the size of the titanic
and a giraffe and a giraffe and gigi
gigi the giraffe